welcome to this video j'adoube first is
my opponent ok that's a good handle
never how I played him two times didn't
expect that ok gotta jump off he dropped
off ski I don't know and he's playing
interesting interesting manner he woulda
form ah how do I play that probably
something like that I don't want to grab
the point i don't like that but ok maybe
maybe this kind of thing he probably
will play a 67 later Bishop takes Bishop
takes d5 97 e 644 for a weird structure
no it's not doing that ok so he's just
he's just giving up his all of his
bishops for some attacking ideas ok if i
take c 3 or take him
I take here then queen-to-be aid getting
trying to gain a tempo mean this is I
have wow wow okay jack okay he's just
getting just allowing an end game where
I have I mean two bishops against two
nights so with good technical play black
should already be winning him but okay
still need to be precise hmm okay so
he's cutting his gut in some activity
yeah probably here prevent 9700 take on
h2 yeah the two bishops against two
nights with them even even bonds is
really really a lot especially if there
are no no excellent outposts for the
Knights and in this case the nights are
really am without any our posts I mean
d5 is not a stable Squared's it would be
a little bit different if my Paul was
Ali fire for example then he has a nice
square on e4 but when even that would be
quite clearly better for black but in
this in this version it's very nice yeah
i also want to mention that I'm
approaching the two thousand mark in
blitz games and this is quite quite nice
of course um someone mentioned that i
should try to to go for
2500 yeah for this landmark figure well
I'll try but it's not easy okay I don't
want to give up the bishop if we
actually had an idea I wasn't really
getting it the idea but it's intended to
play night before okay yeah it's not a
big deal to remove the bishop you put it
on the aid at least I don't don't see a
problem ok I can go a five kick kick the
night bag maybe not an ideal move but
I need to untangle 93 I guess and Bishop
c6
okay yeah well I still don't want to
trade i might play 95 and so i probably
should go here I think that's not so
dangerous
b6 no I say I think I should just keep
it just keep it like that and maybe king
of 87 this is this type of thing this is
really not ingest worried or remarkable
I really wouldn't wouldn't allow all the
trades he has white bits okay let's see
if I 4g 5m many many nice ideas
yeah should I go b6 here or yeah be six
maybe you cannot play Knight a six
because of the should be five check so
he has to retreat and now probably g5 h5
this kind of thing
guys his passport is not very dangerous
really okay so G form or the check first
yeah maybe the check first well now
let's start with this it's probably even
better than checking here and then take
a not sure about the most precise move
on em Jerry the Knights really AM are
clumsy pieces and this this kind of
position they really don't have anything
great to go great to go to and I go King
d6 king d 5 next it's also f4 but I only
want to play this when my king is on d5
already
okay what is running out of moves them
that that's a problem k 93 should I go F
form or I can just take it yeah hmm
that's also not bad at all take f1 now
okay that's that's the simplest solution
I guess Bishop against Knight is also
very much favorable for black because
the B porn is just week and will be
probably will be dropped a night morning
bishop t4 and then King c4 or king d for
King divorce easy wait for things on
time yeah he lost some time this is just
lost him the B porn would drop and then
I will win with three against two yeah
he just traded everything down to a very
bad end game the disposition is really i
mean even if he amazed that stocked
fridge only has minus 0.4 here maybe he
said see some way to get rid of one
bishop mmm yeah not this one 93 95 here
maybe maybe this is is possible that you
are so well developed that you get one
bishop that's true whether it gives a
line where one Bishop is getting away
even then black is better but not much
the way it was played i was just just
winning basically i can take h2 we
didn't think about that mostly because i
forgot that i didn't recognize that he
can go here yeah again i can take h2 but
okay I wanted to keep the two bishops
that's a funny evaluation stockfish
minus 0.2 what like a sir is clearly
better to bishops against tinnitus
just terrible yeah yeah yeahs black
should win with good technical play not
sure how well i actually did but it is
it is an overwhelming position i think
it was okay all the time check here the
engine is approaching minus two minus
three HC sound how bad it is already
yeah you simply cannot trade down
everything here somewhere if we could
back him to the actual position I think
here white should should keep pieces on
something like Queen to d4 Queen to c4
and then maybe try to use it as a
development advantage one idea was to go
here and play maybe this was check
catching up in development yeah i guess
in ok game thanks for watching